German automakers are always President
car shows in China whether in Beijing or
as this time shanghai Geneva's nope are
Carmen Montes kirat says Chinese
automakers are often accused of copying
the designs of other brands like with
the car behind him but he says Chinese
car makers are in some respects very
advanced and even ahead of the rivals as
highlighted once again by this car and
no other auto show in the world has so
many electric and self-driving cars as
here in Shanghai Alexis father o de alta
Norma's phylum me here in Shanghai
Sherman car giant Volkswagen unveiled
the ID cross concept car a world
premiere the man in charge of brand
management at VW have IDs says the ID
cross will go into production by 2020
the ID cross he says the ID cross is
based on vw's architecture for electric
models there's plenty of space for the
battery for passengers and for cargo
there is no combustion engine its
all-electric the operating concept is
completely new the vehicle will be
constantly linked to the internet and
therefore offer new services and behave
intelligently it's also ready for when
self-driving comes in auto shanghai has
become increasingly important for the
global industry asalamu saudi CEO rupert
stadler says the quality of the car
shows in china has increased
significantly in recent years shanghai
is very international and suitable for
world premieres he's pleased about that
because he finds it very attractive here
there's lots of new ideas many electric
vehicles digitalization is another big
theme so areas of innovation that Audi
is also focused on also a sink Tina
Watson's fail daddy wants him once a
remote mobile segment a big howdy is
also here with a new all-electric
concept vehicle the e-tron sportback it
has one electric motor on the front axle
and two at the rear so it packs a punch
and not to be outdone skoda has also
brought an electric car to Shanghai the
vision E is scotus contribution to a
cleaner more sustainable future mata
says you may be thinking didn't I just
see the same vehicle from Volkswagen the
answer is yes and no a two-vehicle share
the same platform VW's modular electric
tool kit but there are differences in
details and the bodyline give this done
talking off on Tashi do the vision e is
scotus first all-electric concept
vehicle said that friedrichshafen is
also here as a maker of parts it's vital
for the car industry we have a two major
themes we're talking about about
automated driving active and passive
safety systems being combined and
supporting that sort of technology and
we're talking about dried line
technologies in particular e-mobility
said f produces everything from
automatic transmissions suitable for
hybrid vehicles control electronics and
electric axle drives so it's a valuable
partner for companies looking to get
into e-mobility
halden montes says chinese buyers like
elsewhere don't only shop with their
heads but also their hearts so fast
expensive cars are still in was the
all-electric concept car from Bentley
oozes luxury CEO of Condor heimer says
it's equipped with three electric motors
in a large battery allowing a range of
500 kilometers this is what the first
all-electric Bentley could look like
thing and it's certainly not slow the
exp 12 speed 6e convertible delivers the
kind of performance you'd expect from a
regular gas powered 12-cylinder Bentley
[Music]
Porsche is also getting in on the act
with its Panamera a hybrid and the new
Panamera station wagon as elphaba Saigon
Porsche CEO Oliver blue mrs. this is a
whole new segment for the company
linking great comfort with a sporty
nature of the Panamera basic vehicle
it's the first Panamera with five seats
but includes many genes from the 911 and
the 918 spyder ithaca walking home then
you and Porsha has also made an
extra-long Panamera the executive
exclusively for the Chinese market the
new s-class for Mercedes also had its
world premiere here in Shanghai it's not
an electric vehicle although a plug-in
hybrid version is planned the flagship
vehicle is the Maybach as 680 designed
to be the epitome of luxury death las
mercedes buzz dealer said she says the
s-class has always been the ultimate an
automobile construction he says many
would agree that Mercedes has once again
lived up to that standard every time you
think you've reached the limit he says
you discover more progress as possible
if it Novartis's
Mercedes has also bought a concept car
built on the 8th class platform I think
in either contoh says the Chinese
government shocked the automobile
industry when it announced plans for a
compulsory electric vehicle quota which
seemed to come very suddenly but Montes
thinks it was a move in the right
direction and auto shanghai shows its
working with electric vehicles and
plug-in hybrids everywhere you look give
this electro auto sewed up like a new
breed fat soybean